okay
[Music]
okay
so
six five one two one zero zero six six
five two nine appearances on the record
starting with prosperity good afternoon
thank you mark
good afternoon shannon smith on behalf
of jennifer crumbly good afternoon your
honor marielle layman on behalf of james
crumbly
and we're ready to proceed with your
examination i am runner uh
how's amanda
[Music]
this
you're going to give
please keep your voice up
verbalize all responses to all questions
and if you are comfortable you can take
your mask
you have to flex the glass around on
both sides so it's totally up to you
all right i'm going to ask you to state
and spell both your first and last name
thank you
amanda just if you try to match the
volume of my voice then you should do
fine so everybody can hear you
uh you employed a real estate management
company yeah and what is your uh
position there
um administrative admission
okay and who are you an assistant to one
person or one person one person and
who's that kander smith okay and where
is your um do you have an office or a
desk um
and do you know uh jennifer
do you know james
no and do you see jennifer crumbling in
courtroom here today yeah can you
describe something she's wearing
um a stripe
okay may the record reflect that she's
not properly identified
no objection
how close in proximity is your
workstation
to
was your workstation to jennifer's
uh very close across the hall
and machining office or people
okay and are you are you jennifer are
you in jennifer friends
no
okay how would you describe your
relationship
co-workers friendly
did you ever socialize with her outside
the office
and did you
have opportunities to interact with her
on a daily basis
yes
okay
and
would
you share personal uh details about your
lives
together
and
um
did she share with you any personal
problems that she was having yeah okay
can you give give me um an example of
something
um you have to speak up really loud or
take your message but you can keep
convinced
um marital issues
okay
and you did you know who her husband was
and she thought about him by name yes
and who was that
okay and when did that um come up
um
occasionally um approximately what year
what month um
2021. um i she spoke with him
occasionally just you know throughout
the time i've known her um but more in
detail october 2021. okay and is this
something that she would talk to you
about because she was upset or in
passing
so all right and what uh aside from
things that she said to you were there
other other any other signs that there
was a dispute or conflict between
james and jennifer
outside of her talking to me about it
yes
um
there would be a lot of phone calls
occasionally um
but that was about it i'm sorry what
loud phone calls occasionally but other
than that no loud phone calls that she
would keep the door open um
sometimes
um usually it would be shocked
um
you could still hear the conversation
behind closed doors yes okay
uh
what you said they were having marital
issues
what exactly did she tell you
um
that
both her and james had been seeing other
people
and was that something she was happy
about
um not at first
but then it didn't seem like it was an
issue
okay did she tell you that they were
still together
um
they had separated for a moment
but then it sounded like they had gotten
back together and when they separated
you remember when about a month or a
year that was it was 2021 but i don't
recall this
did they separate hustles
no that's my knowledge okay um and
was there any other um
indicator to you that there were other
relationships going on
than just with her husband
yes
what was
yes
uh
the defendants own a duty to the
community to prevent their sons who they
had every reason to believe and solve
was a danger what they did and didn't do
what they spent their time doing what
they exposed their son to is absolutely
material cooperative under 401 and
pursuant to people versus males
there is no duty owed to community
members from just every person in public
so
i don't believe that's a proper
response but more importantly there is
no duty to a community
duty owed to a community that the
prosecutor
argues exists
in terms of the the question itself
whether or not there was some type of
extramarital relationship between
the parties and the duty to the
community um i don't know that that is
intertwined
however as far as the relevancy goes to
the ultimate issue of this particular
case i'm overwhelming the objection you
can go ahead and answer the question
thank you
could you repeat the question yes just
one moment
do you just want to just for to make a
good record um my
the duty oh here is
is to protect the community from uh
intentionally
there's some intentionally harming
somebody when they knew he was
preoccupied with violent material that
they he had access to a gun he could use
it when he wanted to and he was
disturbed it's a parental duty it goes
far beyond careless it's gross
negligence and there's absolutely a duty
and i didn't get a chance to tie that
together but i'll move on what yeah
what was the indicator to you that there
was another um
relationship going on outside her
outside
jennifer lee's marriage she spoke to me
about it
okay did you notice anything um prior to
that
i didn't notice anything though okay
what did she say
she had told me that she had been seeing
somebody else
did she tell you
who that person was no
and did she tell you when she saw that
person
um
after the fact one time
okay
tell me about that um
there was a point where um i had noticed
that she wasn't there in the morning and
she had mentioned that she had seen a
man um
in the morning before during work hours
what do you mean
you noticed she wasn't there
was it before she was supposed to come
into her um i typically got in after her
um i would notice that she
had been there the light was on and
everything but she was not there um and
it would be about an hour until she ever
seen her afterwards did you ask her
about that or did she just i didn't ask
but she had mentioned you know erin's at
first and then um she had mentioned
about a week after that it was
meeting somebody else and where
where would she did she say where she
would go during those hours
um she said that
this person would pick her up and they
would go across the street from our
office
to where
did she say what they were doing
um not directly no okay
and um
did
the uh
did
what did jennifer say about well did she
talk about her son gary
uh no not very often what did she
thought about other than her marital
issues
a lot of it was about the horses um
she talked about she purchased a new
horse which keeps it last year
um and then a
lot of people
okay i'm sorry so i didn't catch that
last time she was she would talk about a
lot of um yard work and housework she
was doing
that
did she say whether or not her son was
aware of these marital issues
um
not directly no
he would overhear fights occasionally
but i i don't know if we've heard
anything else okay
thank you do you follow jennifer crumbly
on social media uh we're friends on
facebook yes okay and
did you ever see a post about
um their son and how they bought their
their son done before christmas the
early christmas present i didn't see
them initially though okay so you didn't
see it prior to november 30th
no i thought i liked it
did she ever talk to you about funds no
okay
do you have a suspicion about why she
didn't mention that she mentioned a lot
of other things
do you know why
no okay um
what uh
you did at some point get an opportunity
to
look at the post
yes okay and when was that
on the day on november 30th okay so
let's let's go to november 29th the day
before
um this
uh terrible um event occurred
did you see jennifer on november 29th
yeah
and
at some point was there anything unusual
that occurred that day
um she mentioned that she got a message
from the school
um but she didn't go or do
okay
did she say what the message was no did
she seem concerned in any way
no
what
how would you describe her
normal calm did she say what she was
going to do
um
with regard to that message or what
she's going to do
no
okay
and
did she say did she mention anything
about how what her son was doing
recently around that time
no
okay
did she did uh jennifer uh probably ever
talk to you about what
how she described her son
um
[Music]
um only when his friends had gone away
that was the only time
okay and did she say specifically what
concerned her about his friend going
away
she was concerned he would be lonely um
that it was
his only main friend maybe only friends
did she say when she was concerned that
he would be alone
no
okay how often did jennifer and james
probably go to the farm
[Music]
did jennifer talk to you about um going
to the bar yeah
um how often did she talk to you about
going to the garden almost lately all
right so was that in the context of
she's just bringing it up or she talking
about her plans after work
um
almost failing okay and did ethan go
with her
not to my knowledge did she ever express
a concern about
her son not going with her no
okay
the next day
november 30th do you remember that day
yes okay what's the first time that you
um
is that something that you would
nearly do
and
at some point um
did
did you become aware of
a call
about her son yeah how did you become
aware
um
[Music]
um
um this was later in the day the first
call was from um the school okay um
that there was an issue at the school
um
okay what did she do after that she
called me and what did she tell james um
did she say how she felt about going to
school no
okay did she say whether she wanted to
go or didn't want to go
no
okay
um did was she trying to ask james to go
instead of her or they were to come too
it sounded like she wanted james to go
um and then
there was another call after that one
and that's when she decided to go as
well do you know what changed her mind
and um
at some point she did she leave
uh yeah okay and um did she come back to
work
yeah
all right um when she came back to work
what did she tell you
um she came over to my desk um she
showed me she said
that she felt like a failure as a parent
and she showed me a photo of um what
even drawn at school okay that was
previously um
admitted uh do you need to see it to
describe it or do you remember the
photo
um i remember the photo okay what
what um
how would you describe the writings on
the
uh
disturbing
okay and what was your response
i told her i thought that was very
i'm sorry you said what i told her i
thought it was scary okay
and what was her response she agreed
okay
did
did she talk to you at all about what
the meaning
um was about or what the school wanted
her to do yeah what did she say
she said that um
that they were concerned with his
drawing that they were concerned that he
may be feeling
badly at fool and that something could
happen
um
requiring him to
engaging counseling and that you needed
to do that quickly
um
that's a big effect did you start i
didn't know your last part
okay
did what was your demeanor when she was
talking to you about this
um my initial
thought was it seemed a little sarcastic
the way that she said that she felt like
a feeling um as she was talking it was a
little concerned um
okay did you have a conversation at some
point about whether or not she should go
and get her son from school
um
did you have a conversation about that
yeah tell me what was what did you say i
said um it would be nice for her to take
him for a day to you know
go see a movie or go have lunch or do
something with him on that day yes on
that day um the david i said she should
have brought them home
and why did you say that
i felt it was
a disturbing photo and i thought
i needed to be around family um
okay what was her response
um she told me that she thought she
would just take him to the barn that
night and you know give him some work
and give him a little something to do
after school
and what did you say to that
i i said if
um
she had mentioned that he didn't like
going but she thought it would be good
for him
what did you say
um
all right um
at some point you
what what happened what was the next
thing you can remember on that day
um after that conversation she went back
to her office i went back to work
and
a little while after
i don't remember all the time
she had received a call and i believe it
was from games that he got an alert from
the school about an active shooter
um and she started to panic in her
office
and i think we all did hearing the fall
um
and
did you
you said that at one point
she told you that she and james
separated but
didn't really
um
move out
and then you said at some point they got
back together
do you know when that yes or no
oh i'm sorry you have to say yes or no
yeah okay do you know when that was or
how do you know that um
she had mentioned that they were having
the issues um she they decided to
separate um how early it seemed um and
then around their anniversary they she
came back from a trip with him and then
she said that they were gonna work on it
and when
was that when was that in the fall i
don't recall okay and where was the trip
um i i don't know the expectation i know
it was a casino but i don't know which
one all right did she tell you whether
or not
they took their son along for the
weekend to the casino no
no she didn't tell you or no they didn't
take them no she didn't tell me okay you
know if they took him
i don't know okay
um
did you ever hear
uh
jennifer talked to
to you or saying passing that she was
taking ethan to the doctor
no
to the therapist no
um did she ever talk to you about the
horses needing medical
treatments yes
what would she say
um there was some i don't remember
exactly what was wrong with them
there was something going on did that
happen
once more than once more than once
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello
um i want to go back through some of
your testimony and just make sure that
i've understood it correctly so if i say
something wrong can you please let me
know yeah
um you were the administrative assistant
to andy smith is that correct yeah so
you worked in the same office jennifer
crumbly worked out of
yeah the same company i'm sorry the same
the same company the same company
and your um
desk was nearby miss miss crumley's
office yeah
and you and miss crumbly you would not
say you were friends with one another
correct yeah but you
uh talked about
little things back and forth when you
would see each other yeah always
friendly conversation
yeah
and
uh
i imagine over time you talked about a
number of different topics correct yes
so when you're talking about the topics
today um
being
their marriage and um
separating and things like that it's
fair to say there were topics discussed
lots of other topics that have not been
pinpointed today correct
yes there were discussions about camping
trips the family talk
yes um conversations about james's
mother dying
um conversations about
um
meals jennifer was cooking
no
conversations about pictures that were
up on facebook
i thought one photo i guess my point is
there were conversations about lots of
different topics it was not like only
about jennifer's marriage did you two
speak correct right
and
in terms of jennifer's marriage and what
you were told it's fair to say that
jennifer didn't sit down with you and
give you a play by play on everything
that was happening within her marriage
correct
it's more like uh you would catch bits
of it here and there correct
she went into detail about certain
issues so there's conversations you had
where she went into detail
but i'll say there were other times
where you would hear her on the phone
with james yes um it's fair to say that
other people in the office may have been
talking about jennifer and james
no
it's it's fair to say that
although jennifer did tell you things um
this was not like a daily event where
you sat down and discussed every
intricacy of her marriage correct right
so there was certainly a time where
jennifer and james um
your understanding was that they were
going to get separated or separated
yes and there was discussion about
jennifer possibly seeing somebody else
at that time
you don't know all the details about
seeing someone else
no no
and the the most you knew is that during
work hours jennifer
uh would not be at her desk correct
[Music]
that's not all i knew but
yes i did know that
you testified that um you would notice
her leg would be on as if she had been
at her desk and then she would be gone
from the building is that correct
and that you were told uh by jennifer
she was running errands at some point in
time yes and specifically
you were told at some point that she had
gone to costco with another person
and
any time that you were aware
um
of her being gone
these times that you're talking about
those were all within the work day is
that correct
yes
so you testified that
um there was a day
that jennifer got a message from the
school is that correct
yes and that message from the school was
a voicemail
i don't know
did you hear the message no do you know
anything about what the message said no
uh did jennifer
tell you the contents of the message no
did jennifer tell you how she felt about
the message
no
what do you
is there do you know anything about the
message
so you don't know the contents of the
message no
so you would have no ability to evaluate
whether how jennifer was reacting in
conjunction with that message correct
the message on the 29th yes i don't know
okay
so when you testified that um
jennifer did not seem concerned it's
fair to say you don't even know what the
message on the 29th was about correct
right
and jennifer
expressed to you that a message had been
left by the school
yes and it's fair to say that you had
never jennifer never told you that at
any time before correct
like before that day yeah
no that was the first passage i knew
about the present school from the 29th
okay so when she got the message from
the 29th and mentioned it to you that
was certainly out of the ordinary
correct
yeah and jennifer um telling you about
it appeared she cared that she had
gotten the message from the school
i don't
um your understanding of ethan was that
he was a quieter kid is that correct
and that he had a friend who had moved
away suddenly so he was lonely
um
[Music]
you were aware that he
were you aware that he had a difficult
time when his uh grandmother died
no
were you aware of ethan's
extracurricular activities no
were you aware when ethan was going to
become a referee for the soccer team no
um were you aware of
um
summer classes that ethan took no
your your knowledge you never met
anything in person no
and
you so really your knowledge about ethan
is very limited
from what you heard from his mother is
that correct yeah and ethan was not on
something or someone she talked about uh
with you at the office frequently
correct
when you testified that um jennifer
was at the barn daily
um
is that your perception of what she was
doing or do you have actual knowledge
that she went to the barn every day
i it was almost every day that she would
tell me she was going after her
almost every day yes
and so based on the fact that um
she went to the barn frequently um did
you have any other awareness of what she
was doing at night or
on weekends things like that
um
no
through her facebook page would you see
the camping trips and family trips they
took
occasion yes
okay so you were aware that um
we have we do not dispute if jennifer
loves horses correct
and uh she would post pictures from the
horse the horses in the farm
pictures of her
family uh camping and on vacation
um you testified that you saw the
picture of the targets that were shot um
that were posted on facebook correct
on november uh 30th
you testified that
you spoke to jennifer briefly when she
came in is that right
and
that you could hear a phone call from
james about a school shooter is that
correct yes was that the first um thing
on your radar
about something going on at the oxford
high school
um at the school in general or even
um either so at the school in general
um
that was the first time i was in school
but i thanked her to call frank prior
okay but that was the first you were
aware that there was a
shooting or a
larger scale incident at oxford yes
um at what point did you see the um
photograph of the drawing ethan made in
the on the map paperwork when did i see
it first yeah um she returned from the
um
when she returned from the meeting at
the school so that was the day before
correct
you saw the photo on the 30th yes okay
and
um
when you
uh you testify that you found it to be
um disturbing and scary correct
uh jennifer was also seemed concerned
about that drawing on that map paperwork
correct
um she
she was talking about whether or not he
would stay at school or if he was coming
home that day correct
no
she well she ultimately told you that
they they left him at school that day
you're aware of that correct yes
did you have conversations with jennifer
about why they left him at school yeah
were you aware that the school told
jennifer he was of no threat to anyone
objection your honor then is not about
evidence
were you aware did jennifer say anything
that the school told jennifer he is not
a threat to anyone now
did jennifer tell you
um
any concerns about ethan staying home
from school versus going because of how
the zoom school year had gone the year
before no
did jennifer um tell you anything about
having the option to take him from
school or leave him at school
now
as you testified that you would have
taken him home as your son is that
correct yeah do you have children
yes how old are your children
young
under 15 yeah how old
are you
i don't know how this is relevant and
it's clear she's not comfortable
answering these questions given
the amount of attention the case is
getting so i would just ask if it just
i don't know why she doesn't need to
know the precise age of other child your
honor she was allowed to give opinions
about what a mother would do i'm direct
i think this is a fair question
background question i would ask the
media not to put this out there this is
not
she didn't give an opinion about what a
mother would do she gave an opinion
about what she would do so i don't know
why we then have to ask her about her
personal life
i don't know how the age and number and
gender relevancy is to the age of the
child
the prosecution opened the door as to
her giving an opinion about a child
whether they should be taken home from
school or not she testified that as a
mother she would have taken the child
home i'm asking her as a mother how old
her child is
arrange okay
can we have an age range please for your
son
okay so not anywhere near a teenager
not even like a middle schooler right
and the day that
you saw jennifer when when you say you
would have taken him home you didn't say
to jennifer you should have taken him
home correct
no you didn't call the police and say i
just saw a very alarming
drawing and this mother did not take her
child home from school correct
you didn't call the school and say hey
i'm concerned because i just saw this
drawing and mother seems to not not be
worried about it correct
you as a matter of fact you didn't do
anything
after seeing that drawing with respect
to the drawing correct
i told her i would have taken my son
home that's all you did though yes
and now looking at the situation
um you have a greater awareness based on
hindsight 20 20 vision correct
some of the things that you're
testifying about
you would agree with me you know more
information now than you did at the time
when you were having conversations with
jennifer crumbly correct
about this case yes
you had no idea school shooting was
going to take place based on seeing that
drawing from that map paper correct
you did not
voice to anyone after seeing that
drawing on the map paperwork
there could be a school shooting correct
i think the gun was alarming i think
that if i thought about it now i think
that
correct i don't think i know that so you
agree with me that you look at things
differently in hindsight when you look
back
you look at things differently correct
when jennifer um did talk to you on the
day of the school shooting she said that
the school wanted ethan in counseling
correct yes she did not tell you she
wasn't going to get him in counseling
correct
she didn't say anything um to indicate
to you then that she wasn't going to
follow the school's
counseling idea correct
she said to you that she felt like a
failure
is that a fair statement yes
and we can agree that jennifer can have
a sarcastic personality at times
and when she said something like i feel
like such a failure
um
it's possible that some of that was
sarcasm correct yes
jennifer did say that night she was
going to take ethan to the barn with her
correct
she did say she did not want him to be
alone correct
i'm sorry no
did she say she
did she say anything about him being
alone
no not that day
did she talk to you about who he would
have been with had he left school that
day no
as far as you knew it jennifer's plan
after work that day was to get ethan and
take him to the barn correct yes and
jennifer said she was doing that whether
or not ethan wanted to correct
she was concerned about being with ethan
after school i don't know
she was planning to be with them after
school
when the alert came in about the school
shooting
um you would agree jennifer was
panicking
yeah
and she you testified that she ran out
of the school quickly
and she appeared upset that she was
running out of the building
and leaving is that correct
and i imagine that everyone in your
office
was nervous and anxious about what was
unfolding is that correct yes
and it was something that all of you
were talking about
um especially because jennifer was
running out the door
and her son went to that high school is
that correct
yes
it's also fair to say that after you
after jennifer did leave that day
um
you sent
you sent her a message
is that correct
and your message was intended to be kind
and intended to be supportive
yes
and you
you pretty much said something along the
lines of thinking of you guys correct
yes
and also that you hope her and her
family were doing all right
that was before you knew um exactly what
had unfolded correct correct
i have no further questions
any questions on behalf of james none
for mr crumley your honor can you
redraft
and it was a romantic relationship
correct
and you asked her or she told you she
saw this person during work hours in the
parking lot possible
right yeah oh thank you
council just asked you a lot of
questions about what you knew and what
you didn't know and if your your you
did you know that
they bought their son a gun and gave him
access to it no i'm judging your honor
did you know
did you know
what was the objection
it's an improper question and the
prosecutor repeatedly keeps asking
questions that are are designed to
inflame the public and make everyone
believe there's access to the gun that
has not been testified to it's not true
and these questions are by design to try
to have these people convicted in the
media that question is improper it's
also assuming facts not in evidence and
facts that will never be in evidence
your honor and if you recall we objected
previously with another witness and you
sustain the objection using almost
identical language
i i've asked those questions your honor
refrain from the
asking the question relative to access
of our sustainability objection okay
did you know that the the gun in the
congolese possession was identical to
the drawing um that their son made on
the math orgy no did you know that the
day before
jennifer probably texted her son lol
just you have to learn not to get caught
when he was in trouble for searching
ammunition no did you know that james
crumbly upon hearing there was a school
shooting went to the house to look for
the bun no okay did you know we called
9-1-1 then and said that i think my son
is a full shooter no okay did you know
how many hours
and hours that ethan probably the
shooter spent at his house by himself
objection
again
question with no foundation
with an absolutely no phone
my point is there was a lot you didn't
know correct correct but just what you
knew not as his parents not what he did
not any of the other things you were
alarmed and concerned when you saw that
worksheet right yes
objection not from mr crumbly rather
i need prosecutors
okay we're going to take a quick break
it'll be one minute we're just taking a
quick
uh signed corrections role patrol
sir if you could please tell us what a
detective in the oakland county
sheriff's office computer crimes would
be better we examined
cell phones computers two president
examinations
eer systems
now in your 25 years experience with the
sheriff's office if you have the
opportunity to participate in specific
trainings with regards to forensic
analysis of computer consultants yes sir
sensor could you tell us a little bit
about that
the main one that we attended is uh an
international certification uh isis and
you have to review that every year
there's a seven month testing process
for that um celebrity is some of the
software we use uh there's training for
that i've been to a certified user for
that axiom software
now sir i imagine that in this
particular field technology is always
changing yes sir would it be fair to say
then that your training is also
ongoing every year yes
and sir you provide us with your cv
my by my account we have 30 trained
specific cell phone houses that sound
all right yes sir
every time you can't actually take a
task to receive certifications yes sir
in your seven years working with the
oakland county sheriff's office computer
crimes you've had the opportunity to get
a data extraction
yes sure
is this something you do on a regular
basis almost every day would you give a
put a number how many times you've
actually done a data extraction
well over 500.
tell us how
this process how that works
so if a phone is brought in by a
detective in charge of a case they bring
it in we hook it up there's a software
that we have a device that you fed touch
was made by celebrate hook it up to that
device
extracts the data off of it and we use
software you've got physical analyzer
usually to examine uh the data
yes sir is that
typically form usually yes
have you ever been qualified as an
expert
yes sir in which course
uh sixth search report
um forty third district court firm
and fifty two two
so six report that is the entire oakland
county circuit court am i right yes sir
so is it more than one judge that you
qualify your next professor all right
what field you can qualify for uh cell
phone forensics computer princess and
call me kill record
um would not be testified to and that's
some of the information we didn't
receive i just want to make sure we're
on track with that no that's that's
correct we're not going to explore the
call detail record
he just has to find that his experience
he's done
okay the court will go ahead and qualify
for his enough members no objection for
mr crumbly either
thank you i would like to direct your
attention to november
2021. do your mind
remain aware of the school shooting an
extra high school yes sir
tell us what you did
i
got prepared i was notified by our
captain that there was a shooting in
oxford and everybody had a goal and i
got equipment that you would need to
deal with a situation like that what
sort of equipment
body armor
um duty rifle stuff like that so this is
you uh detecting computer crimes you
were still obtaining this over here yes
sir
did you actually go to the high school
at first i went to the minors and then i
went to high school and there's a meyer
jason in high school all right yes sir
uh there's a lot of radio tracking
here staging area and
garden center for the meyer and stuff
like that so when i got up there i
wasn't entirely familiar with the area
i'm not from that area so i saw the wire
that's where i went first okay at some
point while you're on cnn were you
requested to report to the oxford high
school office yes sir did you do so yes
sir what was the purpose for you being
cast there to help get the dvr the video
footage of the school
did somebody from the school assist you
with that yes sir who's that jim
what is it role there you know he's uh
part of their security
so in your role as a detective with a
computer crimes unit
you were asked to obtain and review the
footage am i right yes sir did you
actually review the footage of the
shooting november
yes sir
were you also requested to repeat it
from other parts that did yes sir
in fact did you eventually obtain the
entire server principle yes sir
i was a member of the oakland county
sheriff's office computer crimes unit do
you work hand in hand with other
detectives when they do it all the time
okay
so this is probably especially true
now in this case
we're phones cell phones he's from
james jennifer anything from
yesterday
and those receipts pursuant search
warrant yes sir
now in addition to the
oxford high school surveillance system
did you also obtain
surveillance footage from
back requirements yes sir okay and what
you do with that
i um because the way the video system is
broken up into 16 different cameras so i
was able to take clips of the day that
were of interest and stream altogether
okay
now during the course of this
investigation
did you become aware that james crumbley
was employed at the door distraction
yesterday and was a search warrant
executed on the company your damage to
obtain records from that yes sir did you
review those as well yes sir
was information obtained from social
media outlets it was virtual as well yes
sir does that include instagram and
facebook yes sir
now sir is it true that even if another
detective actually offers a search for
return when the information is received
it's a detective like yourself or
computer crime that actually goes
through that information yes sir
in this case you have the opportunity to
review the data extractions from
james crumley's cell phone jennifer
crumbling cell phone
yes sir
did you use the celebrate program that
we talked about
i was fair to say that you're every cell
phone nowadays
so it takes some time to review that
data and export it actually
now tell us detectives someone were to
actually to deactivate their social
media accounts which use investigators
to hope to obtain that information from
the device itself yes sir they tell me
what
you would
it would still be on the device even
though they
deactivated the encounter the databases
that the information stored in that were
able to look at those and then see the
text for the conversation as well back
and forth in the databases
delete the direction
that's different because then
you're telling the phone that it's not
of interest to you anymore and the phone
the operating system will just say the
same room or to make room we're going to
get rid of it now could you as an
investigator in this field still hope to
obtain that data
sometimes yes sir to tell me how but the
devices or the software you use actually
does involve carving for data and it
looks deeper into the
information that was obtained and tried
to extract those databases even though
they're broken up maybe sometimes
now if you were concerned that someone
were going to delete their actual let's
say facebook or instagram account how
would you investigate investigator try
to prevent
all that data from being first you would
serve a preservation letter what does
that mean uh it gives an investigator 90
days to get a search warrant and it's
served on the company whether it's
facebook tick tock whatever and it just
tells them this account don't do
anything with it even if the user says i
don't want any more just save it as it
is right now and work preservation
particularly
now in addition to the data extractions
and the cell phones themselves did you
have the opportunity to review search
warrant returns from
ethan crumbley's instagram account yes
sir about jennifer crumley's instagram
yes sir
james crumby's instagram no yes sir
jennifer crumbling's facebook account
yes sir and uh james crumbley's door
ditch account yes sir and also james
comey's facebook yes
when the crumbies were interviewed they
give the police their phone numbers
yes sir okay then where did the police
also become known you can become known
yes yes sir all right so
what i'm asking you is when you have a
cell phone it's given to you you don't
know who's it is right away am i correct
correctly okay now is there a way for
you when you review the data extraction
to tie in
a cell phone device to the owner of a
cell phone yes sir how is that but
usually the evidence badge that it comes
in is marked as whoever it was but it's
also verified by when we extract the
data from the phone the phone number is
saved in the phone usually on the sim
card and it's just able to read the
phone number so when we have someone's
phone or they tell us where it is
okay so is this this is called user
accounts yes sir okay is this
information available on the data
extractions of ethanol cell phone yes
sir and also the defendant's james and
jennifer found himself
also how many devices were recovered
from
jennifer
jennifer crumley there were
four total cell phones that were
recovered
after the shooting um and their phones
were seized and
then we discovered that through the
investigation that they went and
purchased the exact same cell phones and
then also um two phones two track phones
and what's the track from it's
we refer it as a vertical like it's a
pre-paid performance you can get from
walmart or player all right how many
phones are seats
from
when we say three we're talking about
the original the same phone user versus
yes sir
and what about ethan
just one
now throughout the course of this direct
examination i am going to be referring
only to your original cell phone the
phone that receives in the date of the
search warrant specifically otherwise so
we're clear okay
now as part of your gate extraction
jennifer permanent cell phone did you
review audio recordings yes sir do you
have occasion to identify an audio
recording of the stages of voice you
know november 29 2021 yes sir
so this is people suppose exhibit nine
i believe we have a stipulation tonight
oxford high school and i'm here with the
hopkins who's ethan's counselor i was
just calling to let you know that we
just spoke with ethan had a really nice
conversation um one of his teachers
had sent an email to the office just
that she was concerned because um ethan
when she was walking around the room
checking assignments but he was on his
phone looking at
bullets um and that sort of thing so she
just wanted us to have a conversation we
did he said he sets the shooting range
with you this weekend and we were like
yep
you know uh
you know guns are a hobby for a lot of
people and shooting ranges and that was
perfectly normal
um and that we just wanted to make sure
i had a conversation with him about
the things he searches at school
um
and things versus searching and
searching at home like mr happens give a
good example of like if the teacher
makes beer
um at home perfectly normal and healthy
but can't be using searches for making
beer at school so he had a conversation
he was he was great and he said yes i
get it so i just wanted to let you know
that we did have a conversation with him
and
um
i don't know about five minutes and he
went back to class all right if you have
any questions you can give me a call at
[Music]
two nine five 248-572-9565 five
otherwise um that'll do a great holiday
thanks bye-bye
detective that was a one-minute 25
second audio recording that was the
complete recording from the phone all
right yes sir
now you testified that you reviewed the
data extractions on both ethan and
jennifer
yes sir
we will review a text message thread
between ethan crumley and jennifer
jennifer
yes sir
did you export that to a pdf yes sir
when you review a data extraction
on celebrate you were able to put it in
searchable searchable format yes okay
tell me how that works but there's
within the different tabs either whether
it's a text message or call log or
whatever there's a search field you just
type in whether it's a phone number a
name a keyword or whatever you put in
there and it just narrows down the
search of the information like what
you're looking for okay thank you
now sir this entire text spreads 293
pages with about 1150 messages
i'm sorry can the prosecutor repeat that
and slow down i can't hear
i can't hear him yeah if you could i'm
sorry just slow down a little bit and
then we can hear the full question
thanks george absolutely
the actual printout of the text thread
between
jennifer probably it's 293 pages in
total that's right yes sir okay
so i've just just proposed exhibit 10 i
do not believe we have an objection this
is page 286 to 291 for the record we do
have a thumb drive for the court as well
as defense counsel with the entire
exported text thread but this exhibit is
page 286
so the exhibit itself is a portion of
the thumb drive okay any objections to
the admissibility of the exhibit 10.
um actually yes the
exhibit that was given to me
actually goes through page
293
right
but
you said
293 that's right okay 286 to 293 is what
i know okay no
you're right i said two ninety one i'm
sorry
he said it two pages shorter so i was i
just want to make sure we go all the way
through 293. we're correct we're right
all right so for purposes of uh
admissibility for those documents any
objections that being pages 286 through
293 of the text messages know your honor
come from mr from learners will be
admitted
yes
sir i'm handing you these pages that i
just referred to as people supposed to
send admitted to now do you recognize
that sir yes sir and how do you
recognize that it's an exporter
format
put it publish on the screen
now at the top um
the top right is a green text bubble is
that right yes sir okay this is on page
286 that i've identified and what does
it say at the top there
the sentence well first of all does it
identify owner
it doesn't identify the owner and says
which two okay but this was taken off of
jennifer crumley's phone
all right and who does it say it's too
uh ethan is that the phone number
provided for ethan crumbly yes sir okay
so this message was sent to ethan
crumbly from jennifer according to your
analysis correct and what's the first
message
seriously question mark question mark
looking up bullets in school question
mark question mark and what time and
date was that set that's on the 29th of
november 2021 at 11 53 am
what was the response
he responded
almost nearly after by saying what
okay was there a second and third
response that responded saying oh yeah
i already went to the office for that
and then this is page 287 at the top
this is the blue text bubble what does
it say
it was in first hour all i did was look
up a certain caliber at the end of class
because i was curious and what time did
that sound that's at 11 54.
next textbook
he's saying it was on my phone
completely harmless teachers just had no
privacy
and the first text
from
ethan crumley to jennifer crumbling page
they said i'm all good
i understand why
i they talked to me and they said that
they that is i'm good okay and you're
ready reading this exactly how it's
exactly the page okay
in the follow-up text this is nothing i
should get in trouble about okay what
what time is that son that was at 11 55
also on november 29th and 2020 yes sir
all right
and it was a response there from
jennifer crumbley yes
she responded with you're not they left
me a voicemail
and then there's emojis after it with
hand over face
and what time of date was that at 12 13
um
at 11 29.
sir what does this text here the green
bubble sent from jennifer crowley who
ethan crumbly said
on the next page yes sir it says did you
at least show them a pic of your new gun
what time did you write that at 12 13 12
14 yeah on november 29th yes sir what
was his response no i didn't show them
the pic my god
i only told them i went to the rink with
you on saturday it was a harmless hat
okay now we're on page 290 the first
text from ethan crumley to jennifer from
i had this bullet cartridge in my room
that i didn't
what kind of bullet it was
and it said it was a 22 so at the end of
first hour i just looked up different
types of 22 bullets and i guess the
teachers can't get their eyes off my
screen smh what does that mean
generally i mean shake my head
and what was jennifer herman's response
to that
lol
i'm not mad
you have to learn not to get caught
are there periods in between some of
these words
yes in between uh i'm not in the
beginning of a sentence and in between
the three words of not get caught
what time does she write right you have
to learn not to get caught
that was at 12 31 on november 29 yes sir
and his response to that
ik lol
was there a public response
he had uh looks appears to be lacking
emojis
page 291
i just didn't want something this little
to get me in trouble because well i
didn't want to get in trouble lol
and yeah another text on that
you say i want to hear the voicemail
when i get home though
also i never tried to hide we looked up
the bullet i just didn't think a teacher
would be staring at my phone
did she respond to that she did she
generally responded okay i saved it
and correctly wrong but those are the
text messages from november the 29th is
that right correct okay we'll come back
to this exhibit in a little bit
may i approach it with this job yes
in fact if you told us that you had the
opportunity to review data received from
kingster is that right yes sir okay
did that include
ethan jennifer and james accounts yes
sir
do you know what jennifer crumley's
instagram infuser
it was identified as
gen c
78 jdhn
c78 okay and we're able to find that on
the device as well yes sir
when you're able to locate that
information on the device are you able
to export that to pdf yes sir
this is people's report 11.
so what is it that i just handed you
it's a pdf report from uh visual
analyzer software in wisdom thing
it is uh user accounts is the report
itself and is the username of gen c
jbhnc78
for instagram and so that's how you're
going to verify what jennifer crumbley's
instagram user yes
any objection no objection come from mr
crumbling admitted
i'm just going to publish this
report
so this is the page that i hand you
yes sir okay so under user account we
talked about user accounts earlier so
under user accounts here we have a user
name
and this is where we have jdh and c78 is
that right correct
we're able to determine if james crumbly
had an instagram account as well yes sir
and you recall what his username was his
was his name james crumbly
54321
did you do the same process with the
user accounts
on james crumbly's actual device to
verify that yes sir
yes this is people's proposed 12.
sir what am i handing you there's a pdf
report from the analyzer software did
you obtain the same method did you
obtain the information for jennifer's
jennifer
yes sir okay people move them at number
12. no
none from mr crumbly
any objection
probably
no objection thank you i'll be admitted
sir on the screen here this appears to
be the same type of pdf is that right
yes sir okay but this is from james
crumley and you know that comes with
user account information yes sir and his
username james crumbly 54321 which
you've identified earlier
now referring first to the um instagram
returns
how many known instagram accounts
[Music]
i want to talk to you just right now
about the ethan dot criminal accounts
for pictures and first of all did you
receive information from instagram on
that account
did you have the opportunity to review
that yes sir all right
where pictures and posts made on their
account yes sir
i'm going to show you
this is people's
13.
yes
account
yes sir in that exhibit proposed exhibit
has a number of pages that correct
yes sir okay and is that the information
that you actually received and reviewed
from the ethern.com
people to a minute any objection on
behalf of uh
um
there's no objection to the photo photo
part of it being admitted but there's
some text afterwards that i don't feel i
don't think it's relevant
i suppose i can ask the witness about it
on cross examination it's not
just for clarification and for reference
according to
my documents exhibit 13 is
several pages correct yes sir
how many um do you know 16 17
17 pages do you have all 17 pages
17 pages
it is 17 will the last page is playing i
do have 17 pages um i
if i could just ask the prosecutor very
quickly
i have no objection thank you okay any
objection that we have with james trump
none from mr cumberland okay exhibit 13
will be admitted
and then just for clarification this is
for just the ethernet probably account
ethan.crumbling yes josh that's it
now are you able to tell when you look
at the instagram return what time
something is posted
yes sir
so this first one page one here
we have an image is that right yes sir
okay this image appears to be a
target for holes in it correct all right
we have a taken date and time do you see
that as well yes sir what is the taken
date
taking daytime is 11 27 2021 and 1902
utc now when you see utc without a minus
next what is that it's just that's the
time that grinch meantime where all time
starts and depending how far you are
away from
grunge meantime you you lose an hour
gain an hour and currently we're at
minus five okay so is this picture
actually posted at 1900 hours or
different times at a different tension
and what time is it
i'm sorry you said it was posted at 1402
yes ma'am
take it at 19
no ma'am no it uh it's taken it was
actually taken with the
instagram logs all their stuff at utc
time so the utc was not a 702 or 1902
but since we're at minus five right now
it's 1402 active when it was taken
yes sir i'm not going to ask you about
the other comments that have been posted
after november the 27th
just the comments posted by the user
so page two
at the top we have a text area yes sir
what does that say
it's i took my new sig out to the range
today definitely need to get used to the
new sites lol okay now that was posted
by the user and we've identified that as
ethan probably is that right correct
scroll through to the next photograph
this is the third page of what i've
handed you
yes sir all right and does it have a
date and time take it
yes sir what day is that
taken 1126 2021 at 1806 utc or 306 okay
so the target was taken november 27th so
the picture of this firearm is taking
november 26th correct
and do we have a text associated with
the user of this account yes sir what is
that just got my new beauty today with
heart eyes emoji
six hour nine millimeter ask any
questions i will answer
okay now to the following page we have
another photograph this is also a
firearm yes sir all right and what is
the date and time on this
it's 89 11 26 2021
and 1806 utc or 306 okay mission and
that was about the same time the other
photographer posted as well right
and we have the text box with the user
and it's the same text just got my new
beauty today with the hard eyes moving
correct
the following page page five here what
are we looking at
a picture of someone holding a handgun
towards the board
and this was a um we have a date time
when this was taken apart yes sir what
is that 11 26 2021 at 1806 utc for 306
permission okay and again the same text
just got my new beauty today with heart
eyes moving correct
so when we have the same date and time
with uh multiple photographs that we
have here to assume that it's a one
instagram post with
multiple photographs yes sir
a chance to review some of the other
photographs
of these this is h6
page seven you found that one as well
yes sir
i'm sorry
we know for sure that the firearms are
posted on
what about these other photographs were
they posted by ethan crumbly or they
just shared on his account
okay first of all let's identify what
photographs you're talking about thank
you jose i appreciate that this is we're
starting with what's on page six with
the photograph it's being published
right
the question is whether it's shared
versus posted by you correctly
it would be
look at that this looks like they were
posted by
all right i'm gonna move back down to
where page seven we've already do this
one
hmm
page nine
ten
eleven
and the last one is your honor at this
point um
i would i
stipulate to pages one through five
coming in as ethan's account but it's
very clear that six through 17 are other
usernames throughout the pictures
our next exhibit
is a contact page both james and
jennifer's devices that show they
followed that problem
but as it relates to the pages of the
photographs that's being pages
6 through
16.
please clarify
with the witness
who actually posted
[Music]
um
just by virtue of the information that's
provided on the exhibit
i do have one question
and if you look at the text underneath
the photograph
it has two usernames there
can you tell the report what the
significance is of those usernames on
that particular page those appear to be
state commented on the picture
one says the text is tf the other one
text says so true
thank you
[Music]
so the upload the ip address that was
used to upload
the
photos of the the firearm that had text
that we know ethan made
is different but again a little similar
without double checking being able to
check the ip addresses of all the
uploads i couldn't tell you right now
for certain but the fact that the one
has comments after it would lead me to
believe that that was posted by
friends
page six yes ma'am your honor we i mean
we can explore this morning cross
examination but
these are very different circumstances
this has user names listed that are not
ethan crumbling so we object again
[Music]
on pages one through five where photos
are
we're talking about the picture of the
target
and then there's a picture of a gun in a
case
and a picture of ethan holding a gun
presumably and then a picture of ethan
pointing the gun down
those
those five pages
after each of those pictures
um you can see that it says comments
user
ethan.crumbly correct
okay
on page six
there's a different photograph of like
this ghost face
and in the same spot where it says
ethan.crumbly it says user augusto
ferrari
0227
yes ma'am okay so
augusto ferrari is
and there is nothing on here
showing
ethan.crumbling's name correct on h6
ma'am yes
and
but on pages one through five ethan dot
crumbly
is on all of those photographs
that's right
okay
so the photograph with the white face um
the second page that looks like it's
kind of that same white face page seven
of seventeen
again nowhere on there does that say
ethan.crumbling
and the following page where eight of 17
again it does not say
ethan that crumbly anywhere
practicing
same thing on page uh 9 out of 17.
i'm not offering those photographs to
show that ethan crumbly took the
photograph they're offered because
they're on his instagram account
so as it relates to those photographs
where it incorporates not
listed
um how can you identify whether an
amazon you think was account because
that was the information that was given
to us by instagram from the search
market which still served on them that
this was that these were the
um photos and texts that were associated
to his ethan.com
when you look at the photographs and you
look at the documents is there anything
any reference to his actual account and
if so where is that
to the one starting on page six ma'am
yes there is not starting on page 15 it
does again appear his name even that
crumbly was the
finger the circle finger like that um
and then also for the very last one on
page 16 his name is also associated with
that your honor on the the page 15 and
uh 16 that the detective just pointed
out those are like the first couple of
pictures we have high judgments i
understand i can see the difference
between so the question is is for pages
6 through 14
other than what instagram told you how
do you know that that's his account
based on these documents there's no way
to know
unless we were
we probably have to do a couple more
search warrants on an ip address or
something to see where it came from but
that's usually instagram when we ask for
a specific account they give us
everything associated account that we
serve the preservation later on also
so your honor we would object to part
seven uh pages seven through fourteen um
being admitted we have no objection i'm
sorry page five
six pages
through 14
there's no basis for page 15 is fine
page 16 is fine and pages one through
five are fine
um
you certainly will have the opportunity
to cross-examine him on that and
council's correct i will i will consider
the weight of that evidence as it
relates to those pages and the
information that we just gleaned
from the detective
whether or not we can actually attribute
this to his account
thank you
now
if somebody has just a general course we
have an instagram account you post and
share photographs people who follow you
can view those am i right practice okay
now looking under the devices of james
and jennifer from we're able to
determine if they follow the details
from you yes
sir may have personal ministers yes
contacts regarding insurance is that
right um 14 yes yes sir okay and you
obtain that from the device itself
whichever permanent device itself yes
sir
people move to bit 14
yeah i would object i don't see it all
where it says it's from jennifer
jennifer's device
um detective can you identify
where how you are able to determine that
this is from jennifer probably's device
when i was examining the device i went
to the context within what i knew to be
her caller which was compared with the
phone number and i escorted it from her
contacts
can i ask the follow-up questions
sir every time you actually hit export
and create a pdf it doesn't actually
list the phone's name use your account
phone number right right correct okay so
this is based upon your actual knowledge
your personal knowledge of the phone
data extraction correct
you're on our object i can't i can't see
that from this portion of the exhibit
that they've tendered if you have you
have a testimony so you can certainly
cross-examine them he's indicated that
he was the one that extracted it um and
he is verifying based upon what he did
that this is in fact the documentation
from that extraction um you will have
the opportunity to cross-examine him on
that for purposes of the disability i'm
going to allow it conor i would just for
the record joining the objection and i
don't know if we addressed that before
but mr cumberland be joining any of the
objections we've raised for mrs kremlin
14 was in your hand right now and this
is what the pdf looks like when you
export that information all right sir
now you have 15 in front of you sir yes
okay
is an export uh from james's james
crumley's cell phone for this context
okay and that is um james crumley's
instagram contacts as well
correct okay what does that tell you it
says uh has a contact with even crumbly
um on instagram and he's following okay
you're following
that from there that's
that's uh 15 people move to about 15
same objections same objection your
honor same objection for jennifer
um it's the same objection but your
honor
it's the same objection
um corporal admitted over objection for
the reasons previously stated on the
right
yes sir
sir did you have the opportunity to
review jennifer crumpley's instagram
returns yes sir okay
now were there pictures and posts that
you were able to obtain from that
instagram repair yes sir
i'm going to approach with
people 16.
[Music]
yes sir how do you recognize that it's a
search warrant return out of a certain
no objection to 16 for jennifer
uh no objection
that will be admitted
publish this for you sir
okay again we have
the way the ethan.com account this
account also has post and text right
correct okay so we have the first page
here we have a photograph
right and i want to make sure we're
looking at the same photograph what are
you seeing sir i've seen a target uh
down here it's a portable hold it
okay
so we have a dating time of the
photograph taken
taken
1127-2021
at 1903 utc or 203.
thank you
we have a text associated with that
photograph sir what's the text
it says mom and sunday testing out his
new access present my first time
shooting at nine millimeter i hit the
bullseye
second case do you have another
photograph yes sir
what do we see here it's a full back
picture of uh appears to be the same
target and the target doesn't have a
name at the top
accurate firearms
we have a date time ticket
taken 1127 2021 at 1903 utc
testing out his new xms present my first
time shooting a nine millimeter i hit it
i hit the bullseye that the same text is
the first one
now we have
another picture here what do we see here
that one is a appears to be a six hour
handgun uh not engaged with two
magazines
what's underneath the six tower movement
uh it looks like a pamphlet says atm
youth handgun
at notice
and what time was this taken
this was taken at 11 27 2021 and 1903
utc or 203
and what's the text posted by the user
on this account
same as the last one mom and sunday
testing out his new mexicans present and
first time shooting that millimeter
sir when you as an investigator
obtain data from social media returns
like instagram or facebook are you do
you then go through the devices
themselves to
poorly well other
activities in time usually yes or not
not extensively you don't want to go and
go through the whole phone and change
things or possibly delete things or move
things around i'll just look for small
key things that i i'm going to see when
i start examining the phone from the
data that was
so we've already identified the post on
the ethan.com account of the handgun and
the text messages associated with the
post about my new viewing that was taken
on november the 26th am i right right
okay did you have a chance to review the
video as time do you think from his cell
phone dated scratch yes sir
specifically november the 26th 2021 6 39
pm
video review that yes sir
time
a
and you've already had the chance before
today to view that video all right right
people move to admit this is 17.
the objection from james crumpley
on your ass
probably i know your honor as long as
we're going to watch the video and i can
make sure it's one
absolutely
i'm going to play it on the screen here
sir if you could confirm that this is
what you actually found out
[Music]
so was that what you found out that you
can currently see 26 6 39 p.m yes sir
okay now does this firearm appear to be
consistent with the firearm posted on
the into that currently account yes sir
i was also going to be consistent with
the firearm posted on jennifer
cromwell's instagram account yes sir all
right now this is a 13 seconds clip i'm
going to back it up just a little bit
yeah
it's really the very end the 13th second
here what is this right here that we're
looking at this black rope object that
would be a lot
is the gun lock provided
to
the purchaser of a handgun typically yes
sir all right and we already talked
about that etf notice i'm going to back
this video up a little bit more
sir do we see that pamphlet
yes sir okay is that the same apparently
the same atf youth handgun
yes sir
just for the record that was 17.
sir now i want to move on to
facebook returns
we will determine the username of
jennifer crumley's facebook profile yes
sir and what was that
jc wrongly okay are you able to
determine the username of james
crumble's facebook yes sir
yes sir and printed out how many teams
entire investor thread over the defense
that this report has copied as well
that's marked as exhibit 18.
yes
are you moving forward right now i am as
soon as this is
[Music]
i apologize yes i'm exhibit 18 you do
thank you okay so stipulation is to film
defendants as to the admissibility of 18
criteria
you admit it man first witness yes this
is exhibit
publish on the screen
okay i want to start with november the
30th
okay can you see the screen all right
sir yes sir
so we have
uh blue bubble on the left hand side the
first text or facebook message messenger
on
message rather on november the 30th
is uh from who from jc rumbling okay and
that's identified obviously defendant
jennifer crumbly yes sir okay and what
dating time was this it was at uh 11 30
2021
at 9 33 a.m
if you could read that post with
call now emergency mouse and all the
numbers
now the second message he sent
the first message to follow
uh
sent after that was just the word
emergency and what time is that
9 35
am 33 or 9 35 35
and what was the next message on its
right
i just represent two photos
okay can we able to tell in your data
extraction did you review what these
photographs were that she said yes sir
what are those photographs it's the the
drawing the math test that ethan had
that he had drawn on
and sir the
top
one has already been the
this
is sorry you said you've exhibited seven
what's the other one seven and seventy
eight seven eight
this is the new addition
i hit through 77.
man first
screenshot of the second screenshot
here should be the first okay now this
is people's proposed 78 certainly
recognize that yes sir and how do you
recognize that it's the same
it's a it's a math test a copy of math
test with uh certain parts of the
scribble down okay and
that would be the second enhancement set
yes sir okay
people move to emit 78 on public support
any objection by uh james crumbling no
objection any objection by jennifer no
judge okay so 78 will be admitted that
is a separate photograph that's going to
be
yes
that matches
i'm sorry the first or the second
i'm going to put 78 on the screen to
make sure that we are all talking about
the same exhibit
so what i'm showing you on the screen
right now is this what we've identified
with exhibit 78 yes sir
this was the second screenshot sent by
jennifer crumbling that's right and that
was in a text spread between jennifer
crumbly and james truman correct the
facebook message yes this is my thank
you and that means it was sent by
jennifer to james
and i'm going to put up exhibit seven
right now
and services will be identified as the
first screenshot is that correct yes sir
okay
going back now to 18
which is the facebook message right
between jennifer and james crumbly what
time were these screenshots sent
they were sent at 11 30 20 21 at 9 30
i scroll down and i see
a duplicate message is there can you
tell what happened there it's just where
the software it searches multiple areas
and the device stores in different
places so whether it's under a file
system extraction or what's called a
logical assessment electrical extraction
it's just letting you know that it found
in multiple places thank you
yeah identical thing
okay what was uh the response from james
crumbly to jennifer crumlin
james responded with my god wtf what's
wtf
that was said november 30th 2021 9 44 am
from james jennifer kremling yes sir
what's his next post his next message
rather
that not here yet it's michael murray
and curious foreign
that was at 9 45 a.m
and what was jennifer crumley's response
her response he said he was distraught
about last night
so she wrote he said he was distraught
about last night on november 30 2021 at
9 50 a.m
what was james crumley's response to
that message we talked about it this
morning
james then said you talked to him
she responded with can you call
question mark heading to a school
okay
and then what is this last post here um
first post on page 2046
she wrote that november 30th 2021 at 10
04 am right
and then
at 10 12
she stated but she said headed to a
school
well these facebook messages here that
we refer to
i think 9 33 a.m was the first one and
then 10
12 58 was the last one is that right
right there okay now through the data
extractions are you able to tell that
they're communicating
other than just facebook messages yes
sir okay you have a chance to review the
call
yes sir
in your call logs part of your standard
data extraction information
yes sir
i'm going to
show you for people proposed
19
so that is a pdf export from a call log
data extraction james chrome phone is
that right
right so that's obviously not every
phone call for the history of the device
but that's specific to that date that's
been explored all right correct yes
there's one highlighted portion on there
and what's the date time for that the
big time is 11 30 20 21 at 10 29 a.m
does that have a phone number
who he called it's to
the contact is labeled jen 248-760-7502
and that's the phone number you later
learned to be generous correct yes sir
okay and that's the export that you
received from james crumley's phone yes
sir people move them at 19.
any objection
all right no objection no objection
detected on the screen here
we're looking at the same exhibit this
is exhibit 19 it appears so yesterday
okay
we'll have a portion this is two and
then the phone number you identified at
jennifer crumbly with the date november
30 2021 in the time of 10 29 a.m yes sir
and does it have a length in the phone
conversation the length is seven minutes
to 16 seconds okay so we can tell they
have a phone conversation at 10 23 a.m
for seven minutes is that right
10 29 10
10 20. thank you
we have no objection to the admission of
this but the highlighting the prosecutor
has got to do it makes it look like they
only had one seven minute call when
there's multiple calls between jen and
james like preceding the highlighted
call i can see that i mean that's
clearly visible that there's more than
one call he's just asking about the one
and highlighted so if you want to ask
him about the others you certainly will
have that opportunity
no problem
all right
now were you able to tell if anyone from
the oxford high school contacted
jennifer crumlin in the morning in
november
and looking at this exhibit number 19.
no i'm sorry we're moving on now um
now in addition to the data extraction
that you performed on these devices you
can't testify earlier that you
went to oxford high school and you
actually reviewed the footage
were you requested to review footage
from
the meetings with james and jennifer
currently with members of the astro high
school on november 3rd yes sir
all right you've come to learn that
oxford high school has both internal and
external surveillance camps all right
yes sir
now were you able to determine what time
these defendants arrived at the oxford
high school
on november the 30th of 2012
i believe it was about 10 37 okay now
sir when you went through this did you
make any notes about it yes it did okay
you say i believe if you're not sure let
me know and let me know
preview on those requests
i have no problem with defense season as
well when he's done
am i right yes sir okay so i'm referring
specifically to november the 30th 2021
the time that james and jennifer crumbly
arrive
it wasn't very exciting
and then do you have recollection of
when james and jennifer finally were
actually seen into the office
real quick they entered the office
at 10 39
25 seconds and do you know what time
they were greeted by a school employee
at 10 40.
and what time did they
were they escorted somewhere yes okay
and what time were they seeing next on
the cameras leaving them
they were seeing leaving counseling at
10 53
so this meeting lasted according to your
camera review approximately 13 minutes
yes sir
what time did they leave the school
they left the school at 10
54.
do they arrive at school in one car or
two cars one time do they leave in one
car
one car
what time do they actually leave the
actual school ground
or leave the parking lot at 10 50 stars
so i'm going to show you on the screen
here it's already been admitted is
people six
this is a series of screenshots of
messages between carapanic curacao and
jennifer crumble
i'm sorry what exhibit are you looking
at six six
now sir you told us that they left the
parking lot james and jennifer from the
parking lot together in november the
30th 2021 at 10 56 a.m
correct i'm looking for the first
message
after
10 56 a.m what do we see here
it's a message at 10 58 a.m okay and
we've already identified this against
jennifer
crumbling okay i'll bring some out later
just had to go to my son's school and
meet his counselor
now you've told us
that you've had the opportunity to
review messages on jennifer cronin's
phone all right
okay did you see this particular message
on the jennifer cromley's phone
i don't remember seeing that okay if it
wasn't on jennifer cronin's advice what
did that tell you
yes
this is people's 20.
sir what am i handing you right now
uh this uh this is a map i made
from the door dash uh search warrant
here okay and what did you do with the
information how do you create them i
just flipped marks on there for when the
first door dash pickup was and what time
it was the location of the map and where
that drop-off was in relation to the
from the residents okay now what is the
first we know this maybe ended in 10-56
yeah are you moving to admit this yes
sir thank you
any objection to the invisibility of
exit 20
thank you um sir what is the first
activity you see
after james and jennifer probably left
the meeting in exeter high school
logged
so i want to make sure my times are
right the first
message from
jennifer crumpley was the curapanic at
10 58 crosses two minutes after the
scene with the parking lot and the first
activity in james crumley's phone was 11
am which is four minutes after that
apartment all right the first activity
from the door dance recorder
what is the story
that he had his first pickup was at 1100
and dropped it off at 11 19. so he was
making door gas to it yes sir
and doesn't have the last door desktop
there are a total of four of them on
there the fourth one was at 12 51
beyond pickup and dropped off at 101.
now i'm going to back up just a little
bit this is
it's november the 29th i'm sorry
november the 30th at 1 34 p.m
it's been
remember the 30th at 1 34 p.m it's been
simulated to is exhibit five this is the
911 call judge
sir you've had the opportunity
to
review a
am i right 911 sir
so everyone is aware judge there are
two recordings however it's the same
phone call as just james premier was put
on hold for a period time so i'll have
to cycle through the suitcase
after we listen to this i'm just going
to verify the view that it is
situation going on at the high school
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and my son
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
is
this morning
[Music]
[Music]
i can't give you a thumbs up but we're
gonna give you a call so this is
possible okay
okay
thank you
sir was that a cool and complete
recording of the
because that wasn't 911 fine
that was exhibit five which we have yeah
that's been stipulated
yes
sir i'm going to ask you
about some things from uh ethan
crumlin's phone was found on jennifer
starting first with uh and again this is
the original following
starting with jennifer from these phones
does your data extraction also include
internet search results yes sir
yeah
yes
specifically uh 11 29 2021 at 305 a.m
and that was taken from jennifer
crumley's phone right yesterday from the
data extraction yes sir people move to
admit 21.
any objection from jennifer public no
your
james crumbly no you're right be
admitted
okay i'm publishing on the screen here
sir we have a snippet like you said web
history of four
what is the search terms entered on
jennifer crumb's phone
research clinical depression treatment
options
and what time was that done that was at
11 29 2021 at 305 a.m
and then we have that repeated here
for this entire export fight
so
why is it repeated about this because i
actually what i went and did i clicked
on each one of those it just took me to
a different page you know there's a page
one patient page three of the initial
survey okay so what did she actually a
typed in research clinical depression
treatment
now going back to the 293 page text
thread between ethan crumbling and
jennifer primary specifically pages when
i asked you know about 150 to 152
equals 22.
we have a stipulation
[Music]
it's a chat conversation between
ethan and jennifer okay what date did
that start
starts on the first date on here is
march 6
people move to admit
this is exhibit
[Music]
direct you specifically to the first
text message
on march the 9th 2021 so we're looking
at the first page this would be page
150 of the 293 page text string
and it's uh from it appears to be from
ethan crumbly is that correct right
that's right
jennifer crumbling
all right and what's the first text here
in the time
he's saying can you get home now on
march 9th 2021 at 7 50 p.m okay please
continue
and follow up with there's someone in
the house i think
what time is that
7 50 p.m in 17 seconds
and he says someone walked into the
bathroom flushed the toilet and left the
light on
at 7 50 and 39 seconds
yeah
and the next uh and i thought it was you
but when i came out there was no one
home
uh there's no one in the house though
t-h-o
dude my door just slammed
and what does he write in march march 9
2021 801 yeah
maybe it's just my
maybe it's just my paranoia
in the next message well
ethan says but when are you going to get
home
and is there a response
at some point
not on that day
what's the first response
first response to the next day
at 10 21 a.m where's your dad
it's the last text
from ethan about maybe it's just my
paranoia and then but when are you going
to get home with her at 801 pm march
tonight protester the first response
from jennifer crumbly is march the 10th
at 10 21 a.m right yes sir
i'm going to show you
pages
171-173 that same thread this is exhibit
23.
yes
sir do you recognize what i've handed
you
yes sir and again that is the same
text thread
um ethan and jennifer crumbly right
yesterday
people moved to admits 23. the objection
jennifer uh
james cumberland no objection your honor
to publish on the screen let me know if
you can't read
now
starting with
this blue bubble on the left march 17 20
21 603 p.m it's from youth incredibly to
jennifer crumby am i right right yes sir
okay what does that say it says okay the
host the house is not wanted
okay what's next
he then says some weird shit just
happens and now i'm scared
i got some videos what time is that that
was at 603 for 12 seconds yeah
tell me what's this this text right here
saying
on the next page i'm sorry yes
next uh text says in a picture of the
demon okay and what time of day does he
send the text and the picture of the
demon
that was at 603 in 12 seconds yeah mark
17 20 21 part 17 yes sir okay the next
text
the text is throwing goals in all
capital letters today
also 6 03 p.m yes sir okay next time
next text says
i'm not joking
it fucked up the kitchen
at 6 03 p.m next one
he says i'm not i'm just going to be an
outsider for a while
the outsider for a while
and that's 603 as well
yes sir
and what about on march 17 6 29 pm
629 he says can you at least text back
is there a response from jennifer
not on that date sir
so i want to make sure that we're all
clear these text messages here this was
found on the text message thread between
jennifer and james crumley these weren't
selectively exported this is the way the
text messages conversation was read all
right
jennifer
jennifer and ethan thank you sir this is
the way that the conversation answered
yes sir okay
so the first response from jennifer
crumbly to ethan crumbling on text
message
was this one right here on march 19 2021
at 4 11pm when she writes where is your
dad correct okay
now if we could let's continue
our next text message
march 19 2021
[Music]
7 48 i'm sorry yes that's right at 7 48
pm text me when you're done okay
then 902 p.m she texts done yet a
restaurant
in the next test text message on the
spread from ethan to jennifer crumbly
occurs what time
it occurred
the next time march 20th 21 at 2 33
and what is he right i finished picking
up the room
okay the next text please
i clean until the clothes start flying
off the shelf what time is it right
there that was on march 20th at 2 34 p.m
okay in the following text
following text this stuff only happens
when i'm home alone
what time is that at 2 34 pm
all right and then the last text on the
script
i picked the clothes back up though at 2
34 pm
now
because you've actually reviewed all
three data extractions and all social
media accounts
when you're learning something along the
lines of this information such as on
march 17th 2021
took a picture of the demon we're able
to then go back through
phone to give these
an idea of what they're doing
yes sir
did you do that in this case yes sir
are you able for your data extractions
to tell us
what jennifer crumlin was doing on march
the 9th march 17th march 62.
uh horseback riding
now how were you able to make that
determination the you could go and look
at the pictures and just narrow down
your search those specific days or the
software puts everything in the timeline
so it's just a chronological order
of when things are happening on that
device
and do images stored on
jennifer crumbly's
phone on that device do they have a
dating time stamp yes
sir may have talked about answer yes
this is people's proposed
24.
sir that's the photograph yes sir and do
you recognize that photograph yes sir
how do you recognize it i see it on
jennifer's phone okay does it have a
date time stamp at the bottom yes sir
okay what is the date of time uh march 9
2021 at 4 55 pm
did people move to 24
no objection
no objection from mr franklin
okay what we're looking at here on the
screen is a photograph taken from
jennifer crumble's phone and we have it
taken on march 9 2021 at 4 50 is that
right yes sir
may i approach again
does that photograph of dave times day
it does march 17 2021 at 6 03 p.m people
move to mid-25
any objection
no judgment no objection to mr trump
this is the photograph of james from the
store i'm jennifer crumby's home all
right right yesterday okay and the date
time is march 17 2012 20 21 at 6 03 p.m
yes sir and what was happening at march
17 21 at 6 03 pm on that text message
she even was texting his mom
i believe on the march 17th
as he was seeing
he said the house the house is funded
he has videos and a picture of the demon
okay approach
this is a photographer
sir do you recognize that photo yes sir
how so
and we also have a time stamp on the
bottom of this correct yes sir okay you
care crisis as a selfie all right yes
sir all right this is march 17th 2021 at
6 03 p.m yes sir
and
finally
yes sir how do you recognize that yeah
there's our jennifer's called he's a
move to a myth 27
no objection from mr crumbly
thank you and this was taken march 20
2021 at 12 02 p.m all right correct yes
sir all right again the photographs of
courses
yes sir
now looking at
the data extraction on jennifer crumby's
phone
we can see no text back in relation to
clothes fly off the shelves or steam
demons things like that but were there
any other phone calls or any other
messages on any other messaging apps no
sir
were there any text messages
in relation to
demons or things flying off shelves or
the house being haunted and james
trump's phone
no sir
any phone calls from james kremling to
ethan crumbly during this time
no sir no phone calls from jennifer from
the evening
no sir
let
back to the facebook messenger thread
between
jennifer crumbly and james truman
this is a portion of pages four four
zero to 443
and this is that over two thousand
please facebook messenger yes sir make
sure we're on the same
yes sir
and how do you recognize that
i don't want to say
a conversation with uh james jennifer
okay with my space for president i
believe in situations this is executive
2018
28 yes sir
is that correct stipulation is to exit
disability yes no objection no objection
on the left now this is the conversation
between james and general trump again
the same dates that we were just
referring to when ethan cronin was
texting jennifer crumbly about seeing
the demon in the house is haunted
right yes sir so on the left we have
um from jc romelu identified that it's
jennifer crowley's account correct on
the right we have james r crumbly which
we've identified as james
right all right
so i'm going to go to
starting with
march 19 2021 9 37 a.m from jennifer to
james which you write
you awake okay and then the next message
please ethan elaine
response
james responds um yeah
okay and jennifer she responds with how
is how is he okay what does james run
he responds but he woke up looked like
he had way in all caps too much to drink
last night complaining about a headache
jennifer's response to that
she responded with well
he was really worked up and out of
control so i can see why
okay the next message
all i know is he needs to eat go to work
and work hard not complain and he can
get his stuff back
the next message
uh jennifer's asking you respond
and i didn't get it question mark and
then these responses
uh james responds with jesus
yes
okay what does he write to her in march
19 20 21 and 10 seconds
he said
let me ask you a question
why am i
in your guys room lol okay just so we're
clear the text actually says he said but
you're not actually saying what jason
all right correct yes okay right
and then her response
omg what's that mean for the record oh
my god
um what does james write to jennifer on
march 19th at 10 17 a.m
i totally thought you were giving him a
vanish last night
her response
does he seem better
no melatonin
what does james say i know
but uh jennifer then says
but he hasn't had one before should only
give it should only give him half james
responds with
he is just doing his school says his
head hurts he took so tylenol
jennifer responds with is he okay to
work question mark
jane says yeah
jennifer says does he remember what he
did
james says
dude i am working on a demo right now i
have not talked to him and he is doing
school
and those are facebook conversations
between james and jennifer am i right
yes sir
now
back to
10.
that is the text thread
between
the end of the text right between ethan
crumbly
and jennifer
i'm going to pull that up again for you
it's already been admitted
i just want you to tell us please
what is the last thing
that jennifer crumbly writes
the very last text message
the very last section was eaten and
don't do it
that was the last text message from
jennifer crumbling to ethan crumble that
was november the 30th 30th 2021 1 22 p.m
right correct yes sir
that's right we were talking about
jennifer from this one i want to talk a
little bit about what's found
did you uncover a text message thread
between ethan crumbly and
another individual we're not going to
name but we know that person is a
juvenile
did you uncover a technology between
anything from within that person yes sir
how long was that
there's about 25 000
chats touched back and forth i'm
comparing that text message spread on
keeping premier's
is there anything that's um
remotely close in size or floor at all
i'm sorry close to what anything
remotely close in size the level of text
messages we can currently
no the next closest was just just over a
hundred okay so is it fair to say based
upon your data extraction of each
increments
that is the person you communicate with
right yes sir
i want to specifically point you to the
data april 5th
2021 on that text message thread
this is exhibit
29.
yes
the judge so you're aware we had a
discussion council and i had a
discussion earlier today about certain
portions being danced or not reacted we
have
comply with councils requested by the
unredacted portion
to them is that correct
we have these unrejected portions after
a conversation this morning yes thank
you
which are separate from what you've
given to the coordinator yes
yes
so this will be the new exhibit 29.
with those
modifications i don't believe we have an
objection to the initiability of
existence
but let me ask you technically
this was a portion of the tax master's
drive between ethan
and that judo
practicer okay and on the top of page 29
um what's what's the date and time
april 5th 21 at 12 30
and we already know this is from ethan
from his device from his phone right all
right kisser so on the right it's going
to be green it's going to say owner
right now would be ethan chrome yes sir
it's going to say two it's going to be
personal
right yes
people move to admit 29 the objection no
objection no objection from mr crumbling
okay both council approached
yes sir
[Music]
okay so the green is
home yes sir okay what's the date time
of this first text message april said
2021 at 12 38 a.m
yes
foreign
church
[Music]
what's the first message with the date
time big time is april 5th 2021 at 12 38
a.m
says i'm going to ask my parents to go
to the doctor tomorrow or tuesday again
next one is the same date just a few
seconds later at 12 38 15 seconds a.m
but this time i'm going to tell them
about the voices
okay one moment
okay the third text message here
third message is i only told him about
the people i saw okay what time was that
time that was uh at 12 38 am 25 seconds
and the response in the blue bubble
response was okay
i want to talk to you about this one
right here on page three
april 5th 2021 at 12 39 a.m
what is that text message from
from
ethan says
like i am mentally and physically dying
now that's on april the 5th of 2021 am i
correct right yesterday
now on this
large substantial text right between
ethan crumbling and that other
individual
there were videos in the catchphrase as
well yes sir okay you have the
opportunity to review not only the text
messages
yes sir
is there a video sent on august the 19th
2021 from incredibly to this person yes
sir right
and you get the opportunity to view that
from the data extraction in front of
this phone right yes sir
we'll move to 30.
any objection
you're honored to be honest i don't
unhooked
are you going to show it to her now
before you move to event i'm going to
take a quick break